good morning believe nation today's
message is take criticism over to Virat
Kohli when I was criticized first first
time I played for India I was criticized
for not being disciplined and not being
that focused as I had to be so I ignored
that and then the first part was I
thought okay I'm going to perform so all
these things don't have to bother me but
yeah I mean if someone criticizes you
it's better to actually you know take
the criticism and look into it if
something's wrong you try to correct it
rather than just being blunt and just
ignoring the world and yeah I looked
upon it because I was out of the team
after that for a while and I sat and I
analyzed what I did wrong and improved
on a lot of things and it was it was
good that I decided to take that
criticism and actually change the stuff
I needed to I think criticism is a
double-edged sword I think on the one
hand if all you do is listen to other
people then you're never gonna be really
who you are right you're just gonna be
living to other people's expectations
you're gonna be doing things because
other people tell you that that's what
you're supposed to do and that is never
going to be the path for you to really
be amazing at something but on the other
hand you don't have all the answers
either right you have a path that you're
going down and you need help to figure
it out and you're gonna make mistakes
not everything you do is going to be
perfect and amazing and so it's being
able to understand the difference being
able to understand what the feedback is
is gonna help you get to the path that
you want and ignore the rest I think
it's really important that you use
criticism as a counselor but not a
jailer
a lot of times people use criticism as a
jailer where they're afraid to do
something because somebody else doesn't
agree with them because somebody thinks
that your video was bad now you're not
going to post it now you can never going
to post another video again because of
one person's opinion and I've had people
tell me that some of my videos are bad
my famous story about
how the little man was created industry
executive said that the video was too
long and she'd be cut down and here it
is over a million views later coming up
on 2 million views you know I didn't
listen to him he's the expert but I
didn't listen to him because it felt
like I needed to go and do this even
just to prove to myself even just to try
it but there's been other times when
industry actions ever given me advice it
had to be a better speaker had to be a
better youtuber how to come up with
better points how to be more effective
on stage and so being able to understand
the difference between the feedback that
will help you grow and the feedback that
won't I think is important and that
comes from experience and it comes to me
we'll listen to your gut right trust in
your heart almost all the feedback that
I've gotten from people that have made
me better was almost never exactly what
I needed to hear I had to take their
advice try it right if you're unsure if
you think maybe it's just your ego
getting in the way then try it and see
how it works and then I always had to
make a tweak to it I remember I had a
media coach for two years helping me
with my videos helping me get better
helping me improve on camera and all of
her advice was so amazing but always
seen through her own lens and I always
had to take that advice and adjust it I
would try what she asked me to do and I
never succeeded at doing it it felt
uncomfortable it felt awkward it felt
like it wasn't me when I appreciate the
push and from that push I hit a wall and
then I swerved and made my way through
I grew and I had to figure out on my own
how to make what she was giving me that
advice and make it better make it more
me because she can't be me to make me
better just like when you model success
if you look up to Steve Jobs or Oprah
Winfrey or Bill Gates or Martha Stewart
or any of these entrepreneurs that we
profile on this channel you can't do
exactly what they did because you are
not that you need to take what they did
apply the lessons and tweak it to make
it your own and then you're gonna have
that success and so I think a lot of
entrepreneurs are really stubborn I
think that's a really good trait a lot
of times but I think that stubbornness
can also
hold us back from hearing feedback that
can help us become better I like to say
that I'm open until I'm not at the start
of any project I'm really open to
feedback if I don't know what I'm doing
I have a goal I want to accomplish this
goal and I don't know how to do it I'm
very open to feedback you have an idea
to help me get better amazing let's hear
it you're an industry expert awesome you
you've never seen this before
but you still have an opinion I want to
hear I'm collecting as much information
as possible until I make a decision
until I'm certain until I know that this
is the path I want to take and then I'm
not open then I'm closed then I'm this
is what we're doing at least for now
right like I need to test it out like
this this is the plan let's stick to it
if it doesn't work we'll adjust
but for now I'm done with the feedback
let's take some action and I think too
many entrepreneurs just hold themselves
back either from their stubbornness to
not taking the feedback or all they do
is taking the feedback and that holds
them back from actually taking any
action because they're afraid of being
judged so harsh of the next time use
feedback as a counselor and not a jailer
so my question today today is what was a
single best piece of feedback you've
ever received for your business leave it
in the comments below I'm gonna join in
the discussion super cure to see what
you guys have to say I also want to give
a quick shout out to Peter boar sner
Peter thank you so much you're picking
up a copy of my book you're one word it
really really really means a lot to me
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope we continue to
believe in yourself and whatever you're
one where it is much love and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot events press
hey believe nation for those of you who
want a little bit more about taking
criticism here's a few bonus clips that
I wanted to share with you I hope you
enjoy I am one who always welcomes
criticism I and I encourage people you
should welcome criticism and we bored
enough to give criticism if the
criticism is coming out of benevolence
that I want that someone is criticizing
me so that I can become better then it
is always welcome but if someone is
criticizing just out of jealousy are
trying to pull someone down then that is
not good then that is coming from him
malefic mindset so constructive
criticism I feel everyone should welcome
criticism with compassion criticism with
love is the most adorable thing and it
should always be welcomed you need to
get in a community where you can get
feedback you need either a coach who can
give you some direct one-to-one feedback
or community of friends who just go out
with maybe you go to lunch to them once
a month you share everything you're
doing they give you some feedback or you
shoot a video you send that video out to
everybody get some feedback on it you
create a pour it the PowerPoint practice
it with five people before the big
meeting like get back in the game we
have a community of people who are
giving you advanced feedback before you
release it feedback before you do it so
that you get smarter at all of this
because you know nothing makes a dream
come more into life than when you start
getting feedback from other people about
your movement toward the dreams you know
before I shoot a big sales video for one
of my online courses I'll send it out to
1520 people and get feedback and then
off and go reshoot it again you know or
I'll put it out into my community and
I'll see the clicks the conversions and
say it's not let's do it again
and it's that willingness to get the
feedback that will keep your dream alive
because look if it's just in your mind
and you're just doing it by yourself but
you never
actually get a positive community giving
you constructive feedback towards it it
will never be that but that it will
never be in the social realm and when it
is in the social realm it feels more
real you know when people actually
comment I mean it's one thing to be in
an artist and in your studio painting
for yourself all day that's great
but once you get some feedback on it and
constructive feedback you become you get
that self-awareness and that social
awareness to contribute and create at
another level experience in your
business is important but experience is
the bias and much of the biases people
have from being understanding a business
is not useful and I was going back to
what's useful advice to get red nose so
I always say have some people on your
team who understand the industry or
you're entering or attacking but be
driven by original thinking and what's
more important than experience is the
rate of learning right some
entrepreneurs I find respond negatively
to critique I think entrepreneurs should
look for critique and people who agree
with you are not being useful to you
well you know I have to say you know all
that criticism that came out yeah I
didn't have being kind of a good thing
because one of the things that I wanted
to do is I wanted to actually start a
conversation about slavery about
America's role in it and to actually
take an audience member from the 21st
century and stick them in the antebellum
South and see what it was in heaven to
have a sense of what America was like
back then
and so even the people that have been
criticized in movie and some lot of
people don't like it and I connect and
understand that a lot of people do like
it and they've been kind of going back
and forth and that back and forth is
really what I really wanted for the end
of the day of this movie and I hope that
actually even continues for the next few
years
if you have ever dealt with self
criticism in writing and if so how have
you done it like how have you dealt with
it well I deal with it every day
you want it to be the best that it can
be and so my assumption is always that
what I've written first needs to be
improved and sometimes when it's really
bad it has to be scrapped I'm not sure
that's what you mean the process that I
go through with a book is first draft
second draft polish and I can polish
every day's work so that I can produce a
clean manuscript at the end of X number
of months or in the case of a look like
11/22/63 a little bit longer but you
know that was like the historical novel
and that was a lot like work and I still
got this huge stack of books about the
60s and Kennedy and Oswald in the corner
and I don't even try to look at it it
gives me the horrors but you have to be
careful and you have to be willing to
take outside criticism too from editors
and the more successful you are the more
you need to try to do the right thing
that's that's all I can say thank you